hello everyone and welcome back to the
world rapid the championship
it's a leader as a ferocious versus a
shocker manyara we already know that
Magnus Carlsen won the event with a with
a full point ahead of everyone else but
this is the most requested game by you
guys you guys have awesome taste so
thank you for that it's again from final
round and the two of them still have a
chance that not catch up to Magnus as
they are a point and a half behind
Magnus but they do have a chance to
catch up the Hikaru Nakamura and
Vladislav artemiev and since he caught
faced Magnus Artemia faced dubov
anything can still happen so we're not
going to over calculate that we're just
gonna talk about it a bit more after we
check out the game so a lot is it is at
stake ali reza with the white pieces
opens with E for now I've said it before
this championship started that I'm
expecting all arezzo to do remarkably
well and that it would be really awesome
to see a clash between him and him and
Magnus however that didn't happen for
the entire 15 rounds they went without
facing each other since earlier as a
head up had a great start then I lost
against Duda then a great not an
excellent second day but then in the
third day he just did remarkably well
before facing Mamayev he defeated three
opponents and drew drew only one so
really impressive stuff and now he has
to take on Mahmoud yarv
we have c6 mum Jia goes for the for the
caro-kann defense tonight f3 with d5 and
Knight to c3 the two nights of the
caro-kann with Bishop to g4 and h3 now
and Mama DRF gives up the bishop pair
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
II 6 closing the structure now that the
LightSquared Bishop has been exchanged
with g3 preparing to finger to the light
square bishop mama Yara does the same
with Bishop to g2 Bishop to g7 and ali
reza castles we have night Stewie 7 and
mamita have already played this game
it's hard to say if Reza knows this but
I'm I'm betting that he he was able to
check at least a few of Mama darvis
games before facing him
I'm your had this already in the world
rapid championship in 2016 against David
Howell he he defeated him Howell went
for d3 here but Ali Reza switches the
to d1 so still still not a new move but
here is ma media of who goes for the new
move here castles in 97 are known mama
deriv goes for d4 so challenges this
night and it is as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game so what
happens here I'll address that goes back
nice to be one and now c5 strengthening
the center we have d3 night beat the six
six just you know good old-fashioned
development and now a for controlling b5
address Anna wants to develop his night
via a three to c4 we have castles by
mama drf and now Knights to a three and
here a six preparing to meet a nice to
see for with b5 first Bishop the D to
the this controls the a shorthand da v
square so after Knight to c4 and b5 the
night will have the the a5 outpost so
Queen to c7 and now Queen back the e2
making room for the f4 pawn here it's
possible to go Queen a four to offer
Queen trade but ali reza prefers the
Queen's on the board with rook a to be 8
and now preparing b5 and Knight to c4
inviting b5 so mama Yara pushes b5 with
characters captors and now as both the
bishop and rook control a 5 nights to a
5 we look after c8 by mama DRF and now
Knight captures on c6 with Knight
captures on c6 and now f4 so ali reza
was able to to get rid of his knights
keep the bishop pair and well he still
has to decide what to do with the dark
square bishop but other than that his
development is is doing great
knights the e7 preparing to push c4 and
also if Alireza pushes a 5 which which
it's expected that he will you want -
num-num the influence of this dark
square bishop however then you give up
the the d5 and f5 square for momma Dee
arms night but ok mama door continues
with c4 this is what he was planning and
now we have Bishop to b4 preparing
Bishop to d6 to win some material here
mom Yara goes Knight to f5 now he can
grab this excellent III outpost for his
night and Alireza
invites it in we have G for first nights
the e3 and only now Bishop to d6
attacking the Queen and after the Queen
moves the rook we have Queen to d8 and
here ali reza grabs the rook Bishop
captures on d8 and mama tariffs could
capture and b1 and we would just see a
trade of everything Queen captures rook
captures here and the g5 but then
mamuro's the bishop isn't really doing
all that much
Ali Reza has a beautiful bishop and you
can never get to a eight so the a file
is all addresses to use as he pleases
so instead mama drf decides to keep the
monster night instead he plays the rook
captures on b8 and okay we have g5 now
the the dark square bishop is not not
really a useful piece with h6 and now h4
just keeping the the dragon in his cage
and here mama your of could bail out and
and just grab the night grab the rook
and play this pretty much equal equal
position but mamedyarov decides to keep
it and go Bishop to f8 he wants to bring
the bishop over to be for now we have
now looked dc1 Ali Reza says okay you
don't want the exchange I'm keeping it
and I'm gonna play against your monster
night we have h k % g 5h captures and
kink the g7 now hoping to get rid of the
bishop and perhaps use the H file at the
to be infiltrated by the Queen Queen to
f2 by Alireza and now comes the Bishop
to b4 so c c3 might be an idea in the
future we have b3 by allah reza breaking
up this structure and or inviting the
pawn to c3 but then it's just a closed
structure nothing is ever happening here
so Quinta h8 by Mahmoud yarv and now
comes B captures on c4 with B captures
on c4 and rook see the b1 now and here
what do you play here it's a very
interesting position what would you play
here feel free to pause the video and
try to find the best move for Mahmud
yarv
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who found bishops
2c3 congratulations it is the absolute
best move in the position and for those
who just want to injured show well
that's what the c3 is what you play here
you attack the a1 rook and you attack
the b1 rogue so here we would have rook
captures Queen captures and now well the
the queen is infiltrating via queen to
be 2 so you might as well go rook to e8
attack the Queen Queen to be 1 check and
now you cannot go to h2 because Nagi for
check wins the Queen so you have to
block with the bishop and here black is
just better
it's just a tough position to play for
white and this is what mom Europe should
have gone for however mama Dara went for
Queen to h5 and this will prove to be
problematic how do you how do you get
the Queen away from there and well into
the game here allah reza immediately
went for rook to e8 he offered the rook
trade and now if rho captures Bishop
captures and the Queen to g4 check it's
not a problem just king h1 and now if
you repeat Queen to h5 check Queen to h2
otherwise it is very happy with the
Queen trade as he's up the exchange
so my PRF has to create some sort of an
attack here mama dr goes rook the B 6
avoids the trade and here comes a move
that really helps Ally Reza out how the
rest goes for Bishop to f3 and now you
see the problem the Queen has to move
and the next move well I will ask you
what to do next
but here at mama your plate Queen to h3
but now feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning move for ali
reza well i'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting that well there there's a mate
threat lurking on h8 and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's queen
to h2 this is how ali reza is able to
trade queens because now Queen captures
is met with Queen to h8 mate again with
the rise but yeah after this squint H to
move mom Yahoo doesn't have a choice he
has to trade Queens so Queen captures on
h2 we have King captures on h2 and now
Knight captures and c2 mom your grabs
upon but it's not a problem D captures
and c4 our leaders are now also
get get a past c-pawn my media pushes d3
but it's not a problem because ali reza
has a light square bishop only Ali Reza
has a light square bishop and the d1 the
queening square is a light square which
will be problem for my MIDI RF and it's
defended twice so Bishop to c4 now
threatening to win the pawn if you
advance it then you lose the night so
this the next move is forced nights the
e1 guarding it and now rook to d8 going
after the d3 pawn here mama DRI pushes
d2 and well there are a lot of things
you can do here but Alireza just ends
the game in the in the world in the
quickest possible manner he just plays
rook captures and e2 and it was in this
position that shot where mom resigned
the game unmoved 41 even though he had
like four and a half minutes on the
clock other days ahead a minute
but mama deriv knows that holidays are
holidays a minute is like you know
enough for for a whole game here he
resigns because although it seems like
you can grab a lot of material here you
can grab this you can grab this you can
grab this well well all that is true
extra points for those of you who who
realized the special relationship
between the bishop and the night what I
mean by this is after the rook is
captured you have to capture the work if
you don't rule b2 just wins a lot of
material for white so you have to
capture it
rook captures some b6 yes you get Bishop
captures with check King h3 and now it
doesn't matter what you grab let's say
something like this point is roped a b1
and the bishop controls all of the
squares the knight can use the escape so
your only defense is Bishop to b2 but
now just c5 and the pawn is Queenie
problem is after King f8 c6 King a 7 c7
now you don't have King D 7 because of
rook to d1 pinning the bishop and well
after you capture it just captures and
you're gonna lose the night as well
because the bishop still controls all of
the squares the knight can use to escape
so next move you're just gonna attack it
and pick it up so that's why mama D all
reside even though it seems like yes you
are grabbing a lot of material even with
check all that doesn't matter
so really impressive how it has a played
this mayara did not
won't draw in the final round that also
helped Eliza grabbing a full point and
memorial also wanted to win this he
didn't want to go for that rook trade he
wanted to give up the exchange to keep
the monster night but when he had find
the crucial bishop the seats removed to
continue with advantage he missed that
and that was all ali reza needed to grab
a full point against a monster like
chakra mama dr what this means for the
final standings is next here I have
prepared the final standings what not
that because artemiev drew against dubov
and because nakamura draw against
carlson allah Reza catches up to him and
he is now second so it's Magnus Carlsen
in first place and Alvarez after OSHA
grabs a 2nd place in the world rabbit
championship and you can see that his
starting number is 69 which is just
insane that he was able to defeat all
those players then in third place he car
Nakamura Vladislav Artemyev 11 Arjen in
fifth linear Dominguez sixth a young
sister Duda then the nil dubov those are
with 10 points Anton Horeb of David on
Tony Hara and you young ye those are
with 10 points then then with 9 and a
half we have shot here mommy they are
blocking Liam maxime beaugeois graph is
mirin initially front Malcolm young
Peter Svidler
Powell pankratov Alexandre motive
Alexander II shook Evgeny Alekseev
Vladimir first save me tree and vacant
and Boris Gelfand
those are the top 25 players and as you
can see they are all all grandmasters no
international master was able to that
climb up or all that high so really
impressive stuff by OSHA and here if
you're interested
these are ferocious opponents that he
faced the clinch 2nd place in the world
rapid championship 2019 here they are
and if you look at it only two of all
the races opponents the first to know no
Studer and Anwar is Maga
gambit of are below 2700 so all the
other opponents of Raja face were over
2700 and he he did not lose a game
against against any of them as you can
see
so there you have it those are the 15
points and and if you look at the the
final day you can see that Ernesto in
urk evil Kwang lien Demetri and rake in
van cow and chakra mama DRF out of those
five opponents ali reza made four and a
half points so that's that's just insane
really really impressive stuff
although wait I messed something up nope
those are not the opponents I I was
trying to create a table but then yeah
that's that's not correct he did lose a
game to Peter Svidler and he did lose a
game to young shift of Duda so I created
a bit of a a double table so sorry about
that I really wanted to prepare this for
you guys but yeah sorry I messed it up
so he did lose two games he he lost
against young feast of Duda and to Peter
Svidler but you know in the end in the
final day four and a half out of five
you know just an insane result yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would once again like to thank Michael
Carey Pete spawn robust victor client
David gross content predator exhibitor
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon I'll continue the
world blitz ramp rapid championship the
world with championship and even though
it's a shame that ali reza did not face
magnus carlsen in the world rapid
championship you know there's a thing in
chess when Magnus is playing in a
tournament second place is as good as
first but he might get his chance in the
in Dublin championship so stay tuned for
that thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday